um this is like a hard pivot uh kyle we
didn't prepare the sex in the city scene
we wanted to do a reading of a sex in
the city script with you because we
thought it'd be funny but i don't know
if we have it so
we could just move on from that
we just want to let
where are you guys based i forgot uh
well we're in space we're in space yeah
where but like real life
oh oh we're both in la yeah yeah okay
yeah so like i'll be in la for super
bowl i'm pretty jam-packed but i'm there
a lot let me come in and let's act out
the scene
yes
oh my god can we do that what's better
than audio video let's [ __ ] actually
go there dude i can't i cannot wait
i cannot wait so you're going to the
super bowl yeah i heard there's a bunch
of nft [ __ ] happening with the super
bowl
before we get into that let's talk about
the the big ticket item
how close are you to getting the getting
the jets yeah how close are you dude be
honest
i'm in striking distance like i don't
have the wealth i don't have the wealth
yet
but
i'm
i'm really crafty and i feel like i've
done a lot of things well i have two
significant businesses in vayner x and
now v friends i feel that i'm young
i don't think the johnson's family who
own the jets are transacting anytime
soon and really to be frank with you
dudes like and i think i said on how
built this i don't know if they used it
like i just love trying
like if karen thompson buys the jets in
six weeks and everyone's [ __ ] me
online like [ __ ] you see eat it like
you'd be surprised of like how much i
actually don't give a [ __ ] it's been so
fun trying like the last 40 years like
i've been on this kick since third grade
or fifth grade i don't remember exactly
but like
the game of like chasing something like
trying to strategize and can i do it am
i good enough will it happen will i get
lucky in timing like all the [ __ ] that
you think about when you've made up this
fun goal
has been really [ __ ] fun
i think i'm gonna pull it off dudes on
some serious [ __ ]
i think i'm gonna pull it off and on
some other serious [ __ ] if i pull it off
i expect somebody to make a movie of my
life because that's some gangster [ __ ]
well we actually have some news we
actually have some news for you yeah
dude
we just we just bought the jets
you know it's funny a couple of my
friends made you know i grew up in the
web 2 game and some of these characters
made big businesses made like real money
and it's like inevitable that's like
your friends razzing you like every time
a homie
cashed out for a bee they would text me
be like i'm buying the jets and like so
i've uh
i imagine that was like in response to
you saying congratulations to hey man
congrats on the sale i saw the saw the
tech crunch article thanks i just bought
the jets by the way literally literally
literally saying i just saw the
techcrunch article happen one of the
times
yeah man it's really fun to chase
look i got blessed i grew up wanting to
be an athlete because i love sports
sports sports taught me kind of america
like that's when i became americanized
you know i was born in the soviet union
playing nerf outside watching with like
i moved to edison new jersey these kids
were all playing nerf ball football they
were like hey who do you like i was like
i barely spoke english i'm not even sure
what the [ __ ] they're like you're a jets
fan they kind of took me they took me in
and like it really meant a lot to me
sports yeah and in first second third
fourth grade my hand-eye coordination
was so on point that i was like a beast
i was good at tennis i was gonna
baseball i was good at everything i
could catch i was all that
by fifth grade i was like something's
happening here everyone's getting much
stronger much faster much bigger and
like and so by sixth grade i'm like oh
i'm not doing anything that looks
anything close to that damn
and so then i kind of switched it to i'm
a businessman i'm going to do this thing
so my whole life it was almost like
the booby prize then i got older
and probably about 10 years ago when i
started to be in a place in my life
where i started becoming friends with
athletes i realized oh [ __ ] and it
really hit me probably six seven years
ago i was like oh
these guys and girls this was like their
dream their whole life their passion
they did it at the highest levels and
then your body tells you you can't do
this anymore yeah
and they're 36 33 27 41 and it's over
and they go through a very difficult
transition
like depression like really and and so
like somewhere about five six years ago
i was like oh [ __ ]
i got lucky the thing that i love and
the thing that i'm good at i could be
doing at 80.
your body isn't the variable and so i'm
very grateful for that that's a good
point man yeah everyone goes through
that period or like one of those
realizations where you're like oh [ __ ]
i'm not the best at this i used to think
i was so for it to happen younger i feel
like it's a lot better for me it was in
college when i because i was like a cool
guy in high school and then i went to
college and i was like i'm a [ __ ]
loser
you mean from like your ability to hook
up
no just like
socially like where people saw me in
terms of how funny i was how cool i was
like
you know i moved to a completely
different
[Music]
were you top tier in high school like
[Music]
well he was home so
[Laughter]
your mom thought you were the coolest
yeah exactly
well you know like i said i was the most
handsome i would go around seriously
most likely to succeed yeah and then i
went to victoria exactly and i went to
college and i was like everyone here is
so much more handsome than i am
yeah cody's yearbook was three pages
it was like congratulations a picture of
him and then the end
his mom and then a family photo
exactly so that was pretty shocking for
me no going to college you know
i think it happens along the way in all
categories of everything
and
actually back to the content like so
much of what i'm just trying to tell
people is like and what
and [ __ ] what
okay you're not the [ __ ] fastest
you're not the best looking you're not
the best at school you don't make the
most money and [ __ ] what
imagine your family dying i believe in
that [ __ ] yeah yeah i understand that
it's incredible comedic
fodder yeah and and i love that and like
it makes me genuinely smile on the flip
side
one thing i'm incredibly proud of is the
[ __ ] that comes out of my mouth
i believe so [ __ ] much you can't even
imagine no i i i trust that i think
you definitely have like
it's convicted
yeah
i don't think i really
and i also know that i'm
more interested in being historically
correct then transacting now
and so it gives me this level of like
confidence of like okay i know what my
north star is it's not to get a bag
right now from like a brand deal or like
like i can i'm good at that part it's
about like actually being right about
this [ __ ] because it's like fun are you
good at life yeah let alone and so
it does make me flow freely but it also
requires if you're gonna live that life
so for you guys right in your talents
when i watch it
if somebody's really going there
and they don't have the humility
and like
ability to understand for example
demented garyvee or whatever else you do
they're actually vulnerable because they
actually aren't secure in their
framework sure
[Music]
you